lorsqu'il fait l'admiration des français
ce sont les masques qui sont disponibles
en très grand nombre au maroc à un prix
très faibles en plus 7 centimes d'euros
quand on sait que nous on commence
seulement à en avoir à vendre dans les
pharmacies et qu'on se sera un peu moins
de 5 euros 5 euros maximum ça fait une
très très grosse différence pourquoi
comment plus exactement comment avez
vous fait pour avoir tant de masse qui
passait pas compliqué c'est qu'enfin le
l'état est entré en contact avec un
certain nombre d'entreprises dans le
domaine industriel et dans le textile
pour voir et ce qui est une possibilité
de créer une synergie ont vu de
mutualiser les compétences et de
produire tout simplement un masque qui
correspond à des normes alors les normes
iso mais également des normes médicales
parce qu'on aurait été saisis pas de
marché de masques chirurgicaux mais de
masques de protection
c'est à dire qui protège les autres de
soi même quand on porte le masque mais
qui ne protège pas d'une contagion en
extérieur donc l'idée que tout le monde
doit porter le masque pour qu'on se
protéger mutuellement et donc très
rapidement on a reconverti réorienter un
potentiel industriel dans le textile
vers un textile plutôt médical et donc
il ya eu l'assistance des différents
médecins qui ont accompagné les
entreprises pour le faire donc
et là bon j'ai un exemple un exemplaire
du paquet avec dix masques vendu à 8
centimes d'euros
lorsque je vous montre comme ça tous les
français pourront voir donc c'est un
masque avec trois plis avec un élastique
donc qui couvre tout le visage rond qui
en gris en en bleu donc ça permet de
couvrir le nez l'intégralité du visage
alors il ne coûte pas cher ou une raison
très simple c'est que le maroc dès le
début des mesures entreprises par l'état
a mis en place un fonds spécial pour
gérer la pandémie du colis 19 un fonds
qui a reçu des dents de la part
d'entreprises privées de d'hommes
d'affaires mais également deux
entreprises publiques et des
institutions qui a permis de rassembler
très rapidement 34 milliards de dirhams
pour à peu près 3 milliards d'euros et
c'est grâce à ce fonds que l'état
subventionne des masques donc en réalité
le coût de production des masques et
supérieur aux 70 ou 80 centimes d'euros
mais l'état fait en sorte que le masque
ne coûte pas cher et donc très
rapidement en a atteint un volume de
production de 7 millions de masques par
jour et bientôt on va
c'est 1 8 million de masques mais c'est
tout simplement une logique de c'est un
choix politique se dire
[Musique]